fascinating new poll out from Suffolk
University which tells us that forty
four percent of likely voters believe
Donald Trump is a racist just as
interestingly only seven percent of
Trump supporters think that Donald Trump
is a racist Democrats and black voters
probably not surprisingly were most
likely to say Trump was racist
seventy-six percent of Democrats and
eighty-three percent respectively
suggesting that these pandering 'he's
from donald trump to the black community
recently have not been particularly
useful let's take a look at some of the
data from the pole do you think Donald
Trump is a racist as you see there
blacks and uh people who back Clinton
and Democrats the three most likely
groups to believe Donald Trump is racist
of the least likely groups to think
Donald Trump is racist we see those who
are supporting Donald Trump Republicans
followed by it looks like white people
white people disproportionately less
likely to see Donald Trump as racist now
we've seen some similar results before
we had a Quinnipiac University poll
recently which ask people a slightly
different question do you believe
Trump's rhetoric appeals to bigotry and
I'll put those results up on the screen
this could be a more relevant question
in figuring out how we should understand
and analyze Trump's campaign and as you
can see they're Democrats much more
likely than Republicans to believe
Donald Trump's a way of speaking appeals
to bigotry non-white voters more likely
than white voters to believe that the
way Donald Trump speaks appeals to
bigotry the older you are and if you're
looking at this poll it's sort of like
the middle section of this chart the
older you are the less likely you are to
think that the way Donald Trump speaks
appeals to bigotry I'm shocked that only
forty four percent of voters think that
Donald Trump is a racist and we've
talked about the importance of racist
policies versus a person is racist and I
think Jason that as interesting as it is
to ask people what percentage of voters
think Trump is a racist individual it's
much more relevant to the future of the
con
tree what his policies in proposal
proposals would do to non-white
communities maybe this gets attention
but the important thing is hey if the
guy is racist behind closed doors but
his policies would not
disproportionately affect black people
or brown people maybe we wouldn't even
care about his personal beliefs so an
interesting conversation some this
weekend and the biggest thing they're
slamming Trump on where they were in
favor of Trump because the reason the
burn fear Trump was his health care plan
and give Obama care and then i retorted
I knew this one person and they hired
mostly admittedly legal immigrants from
Brazil in their company the person you
were speaking to regularly highly hires
undocumented immigrants exactly okay and
then I so I proposed to him so what do
you do about your your workforce they're
all gonna get deported he said I don't
care I don't care just doesn't care yeah
ah so that's odd I found that
interesting yeah and this person was not
uh suffering any kind of acute medical
event when they said this to you uh not
not not a new Oh Becca you never know uh
so listen there's no doubt that Donald
Trump is appeasing the racists they will
be his base as president so at a certain
point this whole thing of well Trump
doesn't really mean it at a certain
point we have to say he said it enough
so that he is appealing to a group of
people that as his base will be
expecting him to take certain actions
and on some level we have to believe
Trump is saying what he thinks or what
he would try to do big shocker only
forty-four percent of respondents think
Donald Trump is racist